[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté quel est le menu du jour
aujourd'hui nous allons faire une
terrine de cannes est une terrine de
canettes avec des bonnes canettes de
votre pays c'est à dire des landes de
gascogne
alors que faut-il pour faire une terrine
de cannelle il faut pas mal de petites
choses vont faire des petites choses
minute quand même alors une fois peu
damaniak il nous faut du verglas
il faut de la salade de la ventrèche
niveau du porte des gésiers du foie un
petit peu de muscade de l'ail des oeufs
du foie gras mais nationale pas la
chance d'avoir du beau on peut faire
avec un peu de foie gras ordinaire se
déclasser et des cannettes
voilà pourquoi d'une fois gras des
classes et parce qu'il m'est fait et les
moins chers et les moins chères ces
pages de mettre des bobos comme un
programme première qualité qui est
richesse voilà bon ça va disparaître
dans la terrine bien détendu alors le
canard qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et
afin de découper
oui pour comment alors on va sortir les
magrets et c'est pas facile comme un
oeuf ce pas difficile mais pas comme les
vers et les canards gras les magrets
sont découpées will they are ne sont pas
des magrets de canard gras nordia
l'expliqué donc c'est pas énorme non non
non c'est pas énoncer les badges d'accès
par e mail
alors on les a enlevées des deux côtés
de huy a narré qu'est ce qu'on va faire
du reste du canada on fera un ragot on
peut descendre et/ou fait un ragoût le
métal a soumis un ragot avait des pommes
de terre c'est bon alors on le met de
côté pour le moment les willy et que
va-t-on faire alors avec ses filets on
va préparer la mairie d'indre à préparer
la marinade
alors mettez vous dans cette marinade du
vin blanc or là on va mettre du vin
blanc et de l'armagnac coupe monomarque
on ne peut pas être mauvais évidemment
non mais inutile de mettre des légumes
non non non pas seulement pas cela parce
que la marinade après on s'en servira
oui il veut pas de légumes on voit ce
que nous avait mis assez abondamment
d'armagnac par rapport à la confrérie du
vin il faut comme ça et alors vous
découpez des filets oui là évidemment il
faut un couteau qui coûterait très bien
votre tribu en voilà et la main légère
la mère des jeunes on arrive à en faire
trois droit le droit celui qui tartinent
surfer 4 ce qui fait qu'on supprime
quand ils m'ont complètement le grade
rui la peau il craint on peut les mettre
à mariner tout de suite je pense non un
vainqueur et oui je les savais pas
ouvrir près voilà vous voyez aller je
crois va les faire petit à petit je vais
d saler poivrer et on va les mettre
tranquillement à tremper oui pour les
laisser à peu près combien de temps là
dedans pour une bonne heure une bonne
heure ça suffirait
maïté on en a découpé au filet très
minces 3 et le quatrième braye nord un
carré on va faire des petits cubes
après avoir enlevé la peau oui ah oui ce
serait trop 20 lors des petits cubes
voilà terminé et ensuite par des
salaires les poivrons les petits cubes
aussi mais on les laisse en attendant on
est en attente et on va commencer la
face à lorient ce que va-t-on mettre
dans cette farce maïté et bien on va
mettre notre 23 ans va mettre notre
porte
notre gésiers et le foie voilà vous
m'avez dit d'ailleurs qu'on pouvait
mettre du porte ou du four il faut qu'on
ma volonté que nombreuses à la balle
importance ou éventuels entre les deux
voilà alors on y va vous allez je pense
me donner ça et je vais tourner oui
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude
voilà alors ça c'est les morceaux que
vous avez nettoyer en eux et ouïgours
parce que mon jeu bien entendu vous avez
enlevé le déchet sur ouï dire et la
pauvre voilà ensuite vous devez parler
dans la relation
oui c'est le petit cube de canard ou la
chambre servir à autre chose
le foie des canettes des deux
traitements et bien ça devrait se tenir
normalement et ça va ça brise et de la
ventrèche que vous allez coupe et demi
qu'on avait d'ailleurs ma été pourquoi
est ce que vous mettez quelques fois de
la ventrèche et quelquefois du jambon je
me suis toujours de la vasque voilà le
jama le jambon qu'on achète
oui il est très maigre oui et c'est
cette wii tandis que cette tendresse et
les salles et assaisonner de poivre et
les comme il faut et sarah passe bien
j'ai un bon ça donne bien meilleur goût
alors dans une farce il faut toujours
mieux mettre de l'avant trêve alors
voilà que du jambon oui très bien mais
ça y est oui pourra vous savez tout vous
donnez la ventrèche et ensuite je
suppose qu'on va préparer un saladier
pour mélanger doussard est la voie la
feuillée alors on va pousser nos plus
beaux là ne pas vous savez votre hachoir
immense à la merveille arrivée il n'est
pas usé
bien mérité vous avez plus de force que
moi ça marche mieux
je crois que ça va y être la voix de la
vie travaille alors à en avoir assez un
oui la seconde faille et alors cette
farce qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
eh bien on va monter maintenant notre
thé ligne mais d'abord il faut
assaisonner cette farce la zone et de
soi de monter la terrible pendant la
levure arrive vous allez trop vite pour
vous bon alors
assaisonner cette farce qu'est ce que
vous allez mettre la vigueur du sel et
du poivre
pour commencer delahaye je vais pousser
ça là oui on va y mettre du là est bien
le tout y est oui non c'est bien maigre
vous envahit mètres de là et j'en ai
près des mères mais ça vous le coupez la
vous le coupez très très très loin
simplement oui on lâche aulnoye jeu sur
les mains sur le facil avons perdu
beaucoup de temps même s'il n'y a pas
une verrine
non on va mettre un petit peu oui on a
très bien il y en a c'est ensuite voulez
parler de muscade aux finissants d'août
à l'air on voit la raclée
un peu oui et on va la laisser goût
firent commandes dit qu'est ce que ça
veut dire courir c'est du patois de chez
vous ça c'est comme ça veut dire aurait
été prendre le goût de tout ce qu'on met
dedans
autrement dit il faudra s'en servir tout
de suite tout de suite tout de suite
lors l'écart le de chalus fille voilà
tout un patois mais alors on sarapp une
noix de muscade de la ligue ou patrons
banlieue la rouille
après on va rajouter de notre jus de
matane de marina de van ne pas parler
d'eux ou si c'est vrai ou mais j'oublie
tout d'ailleurs heureusement que vous
êtes une femme que vous ne parliez vous
allez parler d'eux c'est bien fait alors
là il faut pas mettre tous les marins et
pourquoi pas on en a pas beaucoup
non non non non c'est pas ça les
policiers ça nord c'est parce que les
eaux se ses banques pour ceux qui
l'utilisent pas qu'il marche du pâté une
petite tranche de pâté et où il faut pas
laisser se conservent pas voilà pour la
bonne raison
tandis que nous notre patte et qu'on
fait nous
nous mêmes on peut commencer la boîte et
huit jours après qu'un corbeau tandis
que le parti qu'on achète
malheureusement ne me critiquez pas eu
beaucoup plus de tranche le lendemain et
le surlendemain voilà pour le jeter est
alors celui qu'on achète n'a pas deux ou
à trop de films a trop d'investisseurs
on en arrive là c'est pour ça qu'ils
savent assise assez vite et qui prend
une couleur peut-être pas très
intelligent mais un petit peu de tout
mais c'est pas lysiane ça le supporte
pas alors là un aspect là ne me rendais
pas aimé c'est vrai si nous faisons la
cuisine n'a été comme ça c'est bien pour
montrer que ce soit même bien avant
différence c'est pas la peine de se
donner de lens mal ça
alors qu'est ce que vous allez vraiment
maintenant on va rajouter un petit peu
de mal aimé de meo de la mamie d'art de
wii ce qui est fait avec le vin blanc et
l'armagnac pas beaucoup de temps mais la
lyonnaise cassavettes troicki non mais
on va sortir la quantité c'est toujours
à l'oeil à l'oeil
pas la peine de faisait tous ça c'est
comme ça ça va bien le boire
là et on va le laisser prendre reposer
un peu et ensuite on pourra envisager de
monter laquelle exact de morts
exactement
voilà on a pris une petite terrine en
l'air tous cas de plus simple un ça fera
à peu près pourquoi une personne 5 6 6
m6 à abu dhabi toile à bonabéri
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire d'abord alors
à l'agresser on a graissé cette terrine
voilà ces prix de la graisse de canard
de la grenade qui est venu dans les
landes meyer ou le temps pour ensuite
alors on va mettre une couche de farce
oui voilà on va mettre une couche de
foie gras à lui ne l'amène de foie gras
puis après on va mettre des petits
carrés ce sont des petits cubes qu'on
avait peu de temps après voilà bien
longtemps que le maghreb et qu'on avait
salez et poivrez
on va remettre un petit peu plus de
farce même bien et aller on va mettre
nos l'amène de magret marine et marine
sans les éponger ce qui fait qu'elles
ont gagné ou deux russes et la manière
et blanc ça va mais voilà on va remettre
du foie gras alors là comme ses larges
qui forme et très vous voulez ce que
c'est la seule sait le milieu de l'as
terride là et on va presque pratiquement
le maître tout voilà voilà là ça va bien
très bien rentré après on va remettre
dedans farceur on peut dire maïté toutes
les terrines que le même principe que le
meuble on n'est pas obligé de mettre du
foie gras ici on en a on en est mais
enfin où il ya plus celui-ci avait des
foies de volaille on peut mettre il faut
se faire plus d'économies
après on va finir par nous amène la
dernière couche c'est pour ça qu'il faut
en garder assez pour madrid est large
voilà et là on va finir notre un chiffre
encore dues à 6 pour terminer comme
driver pour couvrir et ça va être fini
ça va être fini tout près à cuire
non et pourquoi on maintenant on va
faire revenir dans une poêle d'une autre
étude bien verte bien joli joli sanad
qu'on va retrouver la laitue est prête
qu'est ce que vous en faites maintenant
et bien maintenant on va la mettre là
dessus sur la terrine voilà on la range
gentiment nadeau si vous brûlez non
seulement être très chaud non pas pour
savoir ce qu'on veut voilà nord remettre
les plus jolies cela les choix de par
contre ça y est là et comment va la
cuire au bain-marie
mais je crois qu est ce qu'il faut là
oui on l'a mais la wii je rajoute de
l'eau et rajouter de l'eau
le four est chaud le four chaud il faut
le mettre un très chaud très très sûr et
heureusement que la lumière si si si si
allez-y je crois que cela est bien on
attend là une bonne heure de temps
[Musique]
la terrine accueilli 1h15 usités on
aurait pu la laisser refroidir un petit
peu plus oui mais il faut quand même
montré comment elle est dedans vous
allez pouvoir la coupe est alors coupé
naturellement il va de soi que le
couvercle de salades on ne mangera pas
on ne mangera pas parce que c'est la
seule
il leur a servi simplement garder un
petit peu d'humidité dedans c'est dur à
couper parce qu'évidemment les tranches
de vies en une quinzaine vianne et
celles amassées durera près à sortir
j'espère que je ne vais pas faire de
bêtises voilà voilà voilà m comme ça il
y en a dans toutes les couches on voit
la viande roi le foie gras et ça sent
bon comme toucher 60 secondes
et voilà oui ça n'est pas une recette
temps difficiles c'est ce que l'on peut
la faire plus simplement en supprimant
le foie gras six mois bon bien sûr mais
enfin c'est délicieux comme ça et vous
ne devriez pas la rater alors essayez
pourquoi pas et à bientôt
bon appétit à bientôt
[Musique]